this is the technical difficulties were
playing citation needed joining me in
the studio today he reads books you know
it's Chris Joel did I win one yes all
down then everybody's favorite going
round Gary Brannen indebted to you good
and the bouncy smell on the internet man
gray good morrow YouTube in front of me
I have a Wikipedia article and these
folks can't just see it every fact they
get right is a point and a ding and a
special prize for particular answers
which is today we are talking about be
Centennial light
oh that sounds highbrow and
commemorative Oh as it as opposed to low
bruh look around
Dave's dead know it we're commemorating
this with a giant brass ass this is
neither high ground nor commemorative
but is it in Britain I know we're over
in the u.s. here Oh Livermore California
I know what it is oh it's the really
really old lightbulb point right so hey
how old's this light bulb have a guess
from the name okay fair enough yeah no
no fair fight actually but it's
obviously more than 100 isn't it now is
the Edison's I know it says 60 watt
mass-produced light bulbs from the late
1890s Oh stardom oh wow okay that's is
it on all the time or occasionally all
the time time ill it's had a couple of
dropouts when it's been power cuts Adam
there too but the mold has remained yeah
right but I find this really interesting
because I read a Thomas Pynchon novel
where in one of the characters is an
immortal light bulb gravity's rainbow
yeah yes which is weird because at the
tie it goes into this whole thing and it
turns out there is a conspiracy amongst
the major light bulb manufacturers do
not produce anything that burns too much
over a thousand hours so that they can
keep producing light bulbs
oh yeah that is actually referencing the
artal is cited as evidence for planned
obsolescence point way
so it's a light bulb that's never bust
yeah yeah but if you leave it on forever
like it's the OP turning on and off of
things yeah yeah if it's on forever then
it it hasn't had the stress I'm sure I
think now if I had a light bulb that's
gone out while it's been on and when
I've been to always when you turn it on
yeah yeah you're right on plink yeah
yeah I don't imagine after a Power Core
turning that bastard back on ah right
yes can you say roughly what the what
procedures were when they had to move it
clenched yeah very fork like you are
about to follow through oh you might put
it on a trolley actually more I think
about it ring the insurance company ring
the insurance company certainly um it's
it's hung up a fire department does that
give you an idea of how they may have
moved it on a fire on a Dalmatian with a
full fire truck escort yes of a point as
fire truck actually would make more
sense you still got your blues and twos
to clear or redson whatever Nelly is an
American remove red residue have a point
um but you've got all that mass which is
keeping the thing from bucking around as
much you know and if anyone hits it it's
not gonna move it yeah also fire engine
electrical device water yeah fight
someone's gonna beats not gonna be on
yeah it's not like the firing in the
[ __ ] I mean when you've got it up in the
fire station there's gonna be someone a
service in an extinguisher at some point
of like you know even if you've got in a
little box or something which I seen you
must do it was transferred in a box born
naturally it's not going to be in some
without the original box yeah is this
stilll thing this this thing still
pristine new in box when it was uneven
cellophane tape a light bulb condition
Near Mint
as new only 100 years just that next
rapollo in the amendment Oh what color
is it see screws Michael that's not a CC
question
it's a fire station it might be red okay
yes no fire station not brothel yeah
although yeah yeah you know it was a
stardom
- confused sometimes Roxanne got a new
job anyway so she does have to put on
the red light now but only when going to
and from a job
Tesla won't have liked it with me Tesla
probably would have liked it Edison
wouldn't have admitted that Tesla like
yes that's true
Edison would have tried to make money
from it you're on something right there
is a webcam dedicated to um what other
thought or what he's gonna be on until
it goes off ah what happened on the
evening of May the 20th 2013 did it turn
off yes it did
did it bust Oddity and that was the
question have a point because all I know
is the light has gone out so they could
they not I just don't switch yeah
well notice connects to an
uninterruptible power supply no this is
a lot of never button ups are light but
before a UPS a light bulb you know what
happened at UPS who died it was
interrupted yes
you know why it was interrupted cuz
someone plugged a cord in the wrong
socket why carpet
so they got a very gently turning back
on again yes I don't know you can gently
turn on a light bulb but unless if I'm
not a penny night but what you say I
defer to Matt but could you not just
sort a dimmer switch deep-thinking
dimmer switch just slowly build up the
core I mean more subtly probably use
something that digitally manages the
amount of current like an electric speed
controller probably but that those kind
of things in GC LED and noise setup Oh
Ryan probably wouldn't what's the
problem with it being noisy you mean a
different kind of noisy electrical noise
you know right the prog-rock
yeah so what's the second-oldest light
bulb then cuz me Nana's out in Avalon
for a long time actually our spare
storeroom like it yeah we lost we lost
the light in the bathroom so we've got
to find something to just do tonight
Congo so it's like we've got this little
back story room right go in pull it well
old forty what not not energy-saving
else well they've been illegal for
however long now well that's quite odd
Woolworths branded purple which tells
its own story so I think we're in with
the shaft second place that's the
question now someone is out there that
but
as the second but you've actually got a
per list here and already someone's
maybe it's like longest-lasting light
bulbs is indeed a Wikipedia thing is
that one in this country we can go visit
uh no the second place one according to
the Guinness Book of Records is in Fort
Worth Texas at the buyers opera house
above the backstage door third ones in
New York City installed in 1912 what did
the owner try and do to to raise his
profile of light bulb to get it to get
up give it a Facebook profile let's get
up the the listing someone going around
smashing second first place he's the one
that plugged up cabling wrong for the
Centennial light Dan downturn scandal
thing isn't it yeah that could happen
did he edit Wikipedia uh no he's
essentially just wrote to all the
agencies saying that it was a fraud
because he was an electrical engineer
and the socket wasn't old enough
Oh smear it was essentially a smear
campaign do you know what happened to
this in the end no one gave that no one
knows the store and the entire block on
which it stood was torn definitely mm
rise that's unlikely to achieve a win
now isn't that someone save the light
bulb well there's also the question of
whether the light bulb needs to be
turned on to count there was those old
doors it's not a light bulb that is it
well it's oh oh wow is there's a deep
philosophical question there's some
light bulbs off in a forest is it still
alight they've got another prize has got
to be oldest working light bulb our boss
because it's this toy of old like yellow
all this working could been brand new in
box from a hundred years ago switch it
on it works oh I've just instantly gone
ahead we all do the one that's been on I
don't know I just think the other ones
be in fairness the other one has been on
yeah otherwise you know you could just
Trump it with a light bulb you out of
your ass 400 years like I said trumpet
Brannan
official arbiter the light bulb was the
fifth longest lasting light bulb tips
which dining let us go the Martin newbie
electrical shop are dated from the 1930s
Oh burned out in January 2001 it's him
it's your man with the freaking label
designer all these building gets torn
down although one burns out
is going round one by one this is
drifting into Pynchon novel territory
again there should be a hoof now you
mentioned Edison oh yeah I'm lucky that
I mention it he designed a bulb that was
supposed to last forever
what was it called Dave never bulb
asraam no they're part of the conspiracy
the magnificent bulb of eternity I'll
give you the point eternal light yeah
it's in the Memorial Tower at the Edison
Memorial Museum as it broke no it still
kind of works but there is there is a
slight problem with it its filaments
about that big across and it needs two
hundred thousand volts to get it to know
is it evil no radiation Oh No No thank
you sir
the slightly bigger problem with its
claimed with the longest light bulb
never been switched on ever
no it just hasn't it just isn't it's
entirely fake yeah it's got a series of
automobile headlights around the bottom
but just make it look like it's turned
on ah
as you said Edison bit of a cheat years
so that brings us to the end of the show
our congratulations Gareth
nice let's don't you you win the
sandwich grill that emblazoned
collectible images of footballers into
your bread oh it's a panini stick
address Oh Americans I'm sorry um has
beaten Christie off goodbye Gary run
good evening MacRay
I've been Tom Scott that's been the
technical difficulties and we'll see you
next time
Mickey Thompson Johnson Mickey Big
Willie Willie dick today no um he was
killed by a stinger and this is a
toughen race so it kills with coffins
shirking boxes fo sure come on over here
the tuner blurted that landed on the
moon on Mars with Fievel - why didn't
like wait he did like he landed in
London a high velocity downward I know
there's a thin line between landing and
impact but there's a wife on the side